This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. At their peak in the mid 90s, there were about 2.5 million payphones in the US. The adoption of cell phones has brought that number down further and further every year. The fully enclosed outdoor telephone box, you know the one that Superman changes in? That is exceptionally rare. Only four of those are left in New York City. That is exceptionally rare, only four of those are left in New York City. After several decades, these little pieces of single-use architecture just disappeared from the landscape. They simply weren't popular enough to justify their existence.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在90年代中期的高峰期，美国大约有250万个公用电话。手机的普及使这个数字逐年下降。那种全封闭式的户外电话亭，你知道超人换衣服的那种吗？那已经极为罕见了。纽约市只剩下四个那样的电话亭。那已经极为罕见了，纽约市只剩下四个那样的电话亭。几十年来，这些仅供一次性使用的建筑小品从景观中消失了。它们根本不够普及，无法维持其存在。
But there's always an exception to the rule. Twenty years ago, a man discovered a phone booth in the middle of the desert that became his obsession, an obsession that he then passed on to the world at large. From the great radio program, Snap Judgment of Oakland, California, producer Joe Rosenberg tells the story of a very special phone back in the mid 90s in Phoenix, where Godfrey Daniels. Uh, my given name is Godfrey Daniels, but I'll go by Doc. He's heading back home after seeing this band, Girl Trouble. And after the concert, someone hands him a copy of their scene.
但规则总有例外。二十年前，一个人在沙漠中央发现了一个电话亭，并对此着迷，随后他又把这种痴迷传递给了全世界。来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰伟大的广播节目《瞬息决断》（Snap Judgment），制作人乔·罗森伯格讲述了90年代中期菲尼克斯一个非常特殊的电话的故事，当时戈弗雷·丹尼尔斯。呃，我的本名叫戈弗雷·丹尼尔斯，但我叫自己“博士”。他在看完乐队“Girl Trouble”的演出后正开车回家。演出结束后，有人递给他一份他们的地下刊物复印件。
Remember Zines, if not, don't worry. They're kind of like a pre-internet miniature magazine. So as I was walking home, I was kind of flipping through it and on about the 34th page, there were a couple of letters to the editor. And one of them mentioned that there was a phone booth in the Mojave Desert, miles and miles from any pavement just sitting by itself. And this, for Doc, just made no sense. I wasn't sure that I believed it. Why, why not?
还记得地下刊物（Zines）吗？如果不记得，别担心。它们有点像互联网出现前的微型杂志。所以当我走回家时，我一边翻看它，在第34页左右，有几封给编辑的信。其中一信提到，在莫哈韦沙漠中有一个电话亭，距离任何铺装道路都有好几英里，就那样孤零零地立在那里。对“博士”来说，这简直毫无道理。我不确定自己是否相信。为什么，为什么不呢？
Well, I didn't have any reason to believe it. I mean, I don't know if, in the age of cell phones, if it's the same, but when you were out in the desert in those days, you were on your own. You couldn't call people. So the idea that there could be this phone booth just sitting out in an uncontactable place. It was kind of like if somebody was on the moon, you know, and you could talk to somebody on the moon. Where did he say it was exactly? I'm like, what was the nearest recognizable landmark? He didn't say it was a really short little paragraph.
嗯，我没有任何理由相信它。我的意思是，我不知道在手机时代是不是也一样，但当年你在沙漠里时，你是孤立无援的。你没法给别人打电话。所以，这个电话亭竟然孤零零地立在一个无法联系到的地方，这种感觉就像有人在月球上，你知道的，你可以和月球上的人说话。他具体说在哪里了吗？我当时想，最近的可辨认地标是什么？他没说，那只是非常短的一小段话。
There wasn't any solid information really other than the number. And so in doc at home he thought, okay why not give it a shot. And I chapped in the number and it just rang. And I let it ring for a long time. And I was just imagining making a phone ring out where presumably no one could hear it except the coyotes. But then there was also in the back of your mind the thought, what if? Like, what if somebody's wandering by?
除了电话号码，真的没有提供什么确切的信息。所以“博士”在家时想，好吧，为什么不试试呢。我拨了这个号码，然后它就通了。我让它响了很长时间。我当时只是想象着让一个电话在一个假设除了土狼之外没人能听到的地方响起来。但你的脑海深处也会有这样一个想法：万一呢？比如，万一有人刚好路过呢？
Who would be out there? Who would pick up? It just really grabbed me. And so I hung up and then I just kept thinking about it. I kept thinking about it all night long. I was thinking about it as I fell asleep and it just somehow got me into its clutches. And so the next morning? I called again. I just kind of became obsessed. Soon Doc found himself calling the phone all the time. When friends visited his house,
谁会去那种地方？谁会接听？这真的吸引了我。所以我挂断了电话，然后就一直在想这件事。我整晚都在想这件事。我入睡时也在想，它不知怎么地就把我迷住了。所以第二天早上？我又打了一遍。我有点着迷了。不久，“博士”发现自己一直在给这个电话打电话。当朋友来他家时，
he'd twist their arm and make them call it. He even put up a post-it note in the bathroom mirror. It just said, did you remember to call the mobby desert today? But it turned out I didn't need it because I used to call many times today. Like how many times? If I was supposed to be working, I was probably calling at least once an hour. And again, this is all assuming that it actually existed, which I had no proof of. Like on speakerphone or like you would stop everything? No, no, no, no, because I would require explanations. I would just, you know, have the phone kind of cradle against my ear.
他会软磨硬泡让他们也打。他甚至在浴室镜子上贴了一张便利贴。上面写着：“你今天记得打莫哈韦沙漠的电话了吗？”但事实证明我根本不需要它，因为我过去常常一天打好多次。到底打多少次？如果我本该在工作，那我可能至少每小时打一次。而且话说回来，这一切都建立在它真的存在的前提下，而我对此没有任何证据。是用免提吗？还是你会停下手头的一切？不，不，不，不，因为我需要听着声音。我只是，你知道的，把电话轻轻贴在耳边。
You know, just listening to it ring. Doc knew it was weird to keep calling a number with no one on the other end. But if he was ever pressed about it, he'd say it was like being a ham radio operator. One little person, sending the signal as far as he could into the ether. Wondering if another little person was out there, listening in, waiting to be contacted, in that uncontactable place. So, I figured I would be doing this forever. I really didn't think anybody would ever pick up the phone. But then, just one month after he started calling? Just doing my daily call and uh...
你知道的，就只是听着它响。“博士”知道一直拨打一个无人接听的号码很奇怪。但如果有人逼问他，他会说这就像是个业余无线电爱好者。一个小人物，尽其所能把信号发射到虚空中。想知道是否还有另一个小人物也在那里，正侧耳倾听，等待着被联系，在这个无法联系的地方。所以，我想我会永远这样下去。我真的不认为会有人接电话。但是就在他开始打电话仅仅一个月后？我正打着日常的电话，然后呃……
... ... ... I got a busy signal. No way! So Doc actually managed to record that call. I look like I'm an idiot, because I keep saying wow! No way! I look like I'm an idiot because I keep saying wow. Oh wait.
……我听到了一声忙音。不会吧！所以“博士”真的成功录下了那通电话。我看起来像个白痴，因为我一直在说“哇！不会吧！”我看起来像个白痴，因为我一直在说“哇”。哦，等等。
And I thought, well, I must have misdiled. So I dialed it again. And it was a busy signal again. I realized okay, either something's gone wrong with the phone company here or Somebody is using the Mlapi phone booth right now. I was Totally hyperactive. My main thing was I didn't want them to get away like I was thinking I need to catch it right when they hang up that phone So I just read I'll I'll read out, and then it rang.
我想，好吧，我一定拨错号了。于是我又拨了一遍。还是忙音。我意识到，好吧，要么是电话公司出了什么故障，要么就是有人现在正在用莫哈韦电话亭。我当时超级兴奋。我最在意的是我不想让他们溜走，我心想我得在他们挂断电话的那一刻接通它。所以我重新拨了，然后它就响了。
And it rang, it rang. Four or five times, I thought, ah crap. And then I heard a voice say hello. Sadly, Doc was only able to properly record his own words at this now historic moment. But as many times as I had called, I had given remarkably little thought if any to what I would say, you know, and I said, uh, Hello. Uh, are you in the Mojave Desert?
它响了，一直响。响了四五次，我想，糟了。然后我听到一个声音说“喂”。遗憾的是，在这样一个历史性的时刻，“博士”只成功录下了他自己的声音。但尽管我打了那么多次电话，我却极少考虑、甚至根本没有考虑过接通后我要说些什么，你知道的，我说，呃，“喂。呃，你在莫哈韦沙漠吗？”
She said, yeah, and I said, you are. Okay, uh, this is going to sound like a strange question. Why are you in I said you are okay this is gonna sound like a strange question why are you in the middle of a hobby desert she said I'm making my calls oh like you live out there and you don't have a phone I gotta say when I looked at the transcript it was kind of funny cuz like you think everything's cool if you're like and she's like cinder mining and she's like cinder blocks and you're like and you're like that's so cool that's so cool that's just so cool that somebody finally answered and she said that she never
她说，是的，我说，你在吗。好吧，呃，这听起来像个奇怪的问题。为什么你在我刚说你在吗，好吧，这听起来像个奇怪的问题。为什么你在莫哈韦沙漠中央？她说，我在打我的电话。哦，就像你住在那里而且没有电话一样？我必须说，当我看到文字记录时觉得挺逗的，因为你觉得一切都很酷，如果你说……她说她在开采煤渣，她说煤渣块，然后你会说……你会说这太酷了，太酷了，终于有人接电话了，她说她从来
heard the phone ring before can you tell your name yeah her name her name's Lorraine Lorraine it's nice to meet you If the phones ever ring it again, pick it up, it'll be me. All right, nice being you. Bye-bye. Was there any sense of disappointment? No. No, disappointment about what? Not at all.
没听过电话响。你能告诉你的名字吗？好的，她的名字，她的名字叫洛林（Lorraine）。很高兴认识你，洛林。如果电话以后再响，接起来，那一定是我。好的，很高兴认识你。拜拜。有没有感到失望？没有。不，失望什么？一点也没有。
Well, let me put it this way. It's almost kind of like the idea that this phone is ringing out there in the desert and anyone could pick up. But then finally someone picks up and it's just Lorraine. Oh, no, no. See, I look at the exact opposite way. Somebody did pick up and I had no right to expect anyone ever would. So this was great to hear a human voice in place of the ringing. I mean, this was a payoff. It just encouraged me more. And the instant I hung up, I kicked myself because I had forgotten to ask her what was probably the most important question, which is where was the phone booth. But of course, I had no way, I had no way to get in touch with her except to find the thing.
好吧，让我这么说吧。这几乎有点像这种感觉：电话在沙漠里响着，任何人都可以接听。但最后有人接了，结果却只是洛林。哦，不，不。你看，我的看法完全相反。确实有人接了，而我本来根本没有权力指望会有人接。所以能听到一个人类的声音来代替铃声，这真是太棒了。我的意思是，这得到了回报。它更加鼓励了我。就在我挂断电话的那一瞬间，我气得直捶大腿，因为我忘了问她可能是最重要的问题，那就是电话亭在哪里。但当然，除了找到那个东西之外，我没有任何办法、没有任何办法能联系到她。
So Doc calls around, does some sleuthing, and a few months later gets his hands on the equivalent of an X-March the Spot map, showing the supposed location of the Mojave phone booth. So I thought, we're all set. So my friend and I took off and traveled all day to the Mojave Desert. And this is in the middle of August
于是“博士”四处打听，进行了一番侦探工作，几个月后，他弄到了一张类似于“X标志寻宝图”的东西，上面标出了莫哈韦电话亭的假设位置。所以我想，我们万事俱备了。于是我和朋友出发了，开了一整天的车前往莫哈韦沙漠。当时正值八月中旬。
And so it's scorching hot just scorching hot Basically as far as you could see you saw Joshua trees and then we saw this little dirt path that was marked You know danger danger warning not maintained blah blah blah. That was the road. We were supposed to take So we were you know, we were just going along going along and the first I thought oh this is not bad at all But the further along that we went the road would narrow. And the thing was that the sun was going down and the daytime you've got these grand, huge vistas and you kind of have a sense of where you are. But when the darkness drops it's just whatever you can see right in front of you.
所以天气酷热难耐，简直酷热难耐。基本上放眼望去，你只能看到约书亚树，然后我们看到了一条标有记号的小泥路。你知道的，“危险，危险，警告，无人维护”云云。那就是我们该走的路。所以我们你知道的，我们就一直往前开，往前开。起初我想，哦，这感觉一点也不坏。但我们开得越远，路就越窄。问题是太阳正在下山，白天时你能看到壮丽广阔的风景，你对自己的位置还算有点概念。但当夜幕降临，你就只能看清眼前的那一小片地方了。
And we were ringed by storms. It was lightning almost in every direction. So then I started to think, if we have any kind of a problem, unless we do find the phone booth, we have no way of letting people know we're really in trouble. But at a certain point, just barely in the reach of the headlights, I thought I saw a line of telephone poles. And there was a little, a little jet to the left, and a little jet to the right. And I brought the van to a stop with the headlights just shining right on the mobby phone booth. It was really, it was really quite a moment. And there's bullet holes in it, there's no glass, it's all busted out.
而且我们被风暴包围了。几乎每个方向都有闪电。于是我开始想，如果我们遇到任何麻烦，除非我们真的找到了电话亭，否则我们没有办法让别人知道我们真的陷入了困境。但在某个时刻，就在车灯照耀的边缘，我以为我看到了一排电话杆。左边有一个小突起，右边也有一个小突起。我把面包车停了下来，车灯正好照在莫哈韦电话亭上。这真的，这真的是个挺美妙的时刻。上面有弹孔，没有玻璃，全都碎了。
It's kind of a wreck, you know. But to me it was just, it was beautiful. I needed to hear that phone ring. I needed to hear what I had been causing to happen all this time out there. So I called, I called my friend's pager and here I am out in the Mojave surrounded by Joshua trees and lightning, and desert. And now there's a familiar pring! It was just, and it was so loud.
它有点像个废墟，你知道的。但对我来说它只是……它太美了。我需要听到那个电话响。我需要听到我一直以来在那个地方引发的事情。所以我打了电话，我打给我朋友的寻呼机，此时此刻我正身处莫哈韦沙漠，周围环绕着约书亚树、闪电和荒漠。现在传来了熟悉的铃声！那种感觉，而且声音太大了。
It was really loud. Bell was just crazy loud. For me, that was kind of the moment, is hearing that phone ring. It was everything that I had been imagining when I was calling. After that, ducked imagining when I was calling. After that, Doc thought the story was over. He did keep calling the booth.
声音真的很大。铃声简直大得离谱。对我来说，那就算是一个高潮时刻了，听到电话铃响。那就是我一直在呼叫时所想象的一切。在那之后，抱歉，“博士”以为故事就结束了。他确实还在继续给电话亭打电话。
After all, someone else could pick up. But that was just for him. He never really expected anyone else to care. Until he did something which would not have seemed risky back in 1997. But which today is obviously very, very dangerous. Gave the booth a web page. And in those days, the internet there wasn't that much on it. So I thought that was about as far as it would go. But yeah, that's not what happened. Next thing, you know, I'd go to my PO box and there would be clippings about the Mahabhi
毕竟，还会有其他人接听。但这只是为了他自己。他从没真的指望别人也会在乎。直到他做了一件在1997年看来并不算冒险的事。但在今天显然非常、非常危险。他给电话亭做了一个网页。在那个年代，互联网上并没有太多内容。所以我认为这就是它的极限了。但是，是的，事情并没有这样发展。接下来你知道的，我去查我的邮箱，里面全是从我不认识的文字报纸上剪下来的关于莫哈韦
phone booth from newspapers in languages that I didn't read. It just spread. So I thought, well this is unexpected. And so when Dock and his friends returned to the booth about a year after his initial visit, when they got there, this phone, way out in the middle of nowhere, which Lorraine had said she'd never heard ring, it was ringing off the hook. heard ring? It was ringing off the hook. You didn't have to call anybody. It was just as soon as you would hang up the phone, it would start ringing again. It was just crazy. You'd pick it up and, you know, who's this person going to be? Where are they going to be? And you had no idea it could be somebody from, you know, Vietnam or Iran or just anywhere. Some people would call and you couldn't talk to them because they didn't speak English. And again, most of the time it wasn't about the content.
电话亭的报道。它就这样传开了。所以我想，好吧，这真是意料之外。因此，大约在“博士”初次造访一年后，当他和朋友们再次回到电话亭时，等他们到达那里时，这个位于偏远荒野中央的电话——洛林曾说过她从未听过它响——正响个不停。听过它响？它正响个不停。你根本不用给任何人打电话。只要你一挂断电话，它马上又会开始响。这简直太疯狂了。你接起电话，然后，你知道的，这会是谁？他们会在哪里？你根本不知道，它可能来自，你知道的，越南、伊朗或任何地方。有些人打来电话，但你无法和他们交流，因为他们不会说英语。而且话说回来，大多数时候内容并不重要。
You're not really saying anything, it's really not the point. It's just the connection. An old trucker guy called and I think he just wanted to be listened to. He wanted to tell stories about his trucking days and he didn't seem to have wanted to be listened to. He wanted to tell stories about his trucking days and he didn't seem to have anybody to tell him to. How many calls did you end up taking that day? It would be over a hundred guaranteed. And admittedly, you're the phone ringing, after a while it'd be like, you get it, no you get it.
你其实没说什么，这真的不是重点。这只是一种连接。有个老卡车司机打来电话，我想他只是想被人倾听。他想讲讲他开卡车时期的故事，而他似乎找不到任何人来倾听。他想找人倾听他卡车生涯的故事，却似乎找不到任何人来诉说。那天你最终接了多少通电话？绝对超过一百通。不可否认，听着电话铃响，过了一会儿你就会觉得：“你来接”、“不，你接”。
It's your turn, you get it. We eventually had to take it off the hook so we could sleep. When they put it back on the hook the next morning, so they could leave? There wouldn't have been a way to leave in silence. I mean, you were gonna have to dress since it was ringing all the time. You were gonna have to drive away from ringing phone. And people weren't just calling the booth. Wow, you guys are so close.
“轮到你了，你接。”我们最终不得不把它摘机，这样才能睡觉。第二天早上他们把电话重新挂上以便离开时？根本无法在安静中离开。我的意思是，你肯定得穿好衣服，因为它一直在响。你必须伴随着响个不停的电话开车离开。而且人们不仅仅是打电话到电话亭。哇，你们太亲近了。
They were visiting, traveling all the way out to the desert, just for the honor of informing callers that yes, the phone booth was real. It's more than real, it's a reality. This is from a short documentary made about the booth, and it's just a montage of people from all over the place, taking calls from all over the place. We're here, where are you? In Glentway, we're from Switzerland, Australia, right on, bro. You were presenting yourself to the world in a way anybody who wanted to could call you There was no control over who could call that phone
他们甚至亲自造访，一路长途跋涉来到沙漠，只为了享受这样一份殊荣：亲口告诉来电者，是的，这个电话亭是真实的。它不仅仅是真实的，它是个现实。这段视频出自一部关于电话亭的短片，里面是一段蒙太奇，展示了来自各地的人们，接听来自各地的电话。我们在那儿，你们在哪儿？在格伦特韦，我们来自瑞士、澳大利亚，太棒了，兄弟。你以一种任何人想打就能打的方式把自己展现给全世界。对于谁能打通那个电话没有任何控制。
He was used to work for the circuit. So you quadrupleed you? You're a paraplegic quad Wait a minute. You got fired from the circuit. It's your best friend left with somebody else How long were you in a coma? A couple of weeks. Yeah, I mean, too. I was in a coma. Everybody wants to tell their story and they want someone to listen to a story.
他以前为电路板工作。所以你成了四肢瘫痪者？你是个四肢瘫痪者，等等。你被电路电路开除了。你最好的朋友跟别人跑了。你昏迷了多久？几个星期。对啊，我也是。我也昏迷过。每个人都想讲述自己的故事，他们想让人听听他们的故事。
It's kind of fun. You should come out and do this. We're putting the whole thing out here. Did you like the fact that it became popular or would you have preferred it to remain? No, first I liked it. The hesitation came about just because once something like that gets out of control, then you know that the equal and opposite reaction is going to come. The only question was when. The only question was when. And then in May of 2000, Lareen's brother, on the way out to the mine, stopped and answered the phone because it was ringing, of course, and talked to some guy in England who was,
这挺有意思的。你应该出来试试这个。我们把整件事都搬到这儿来了。你喜欢它变得受欢迎吗？还是你宁愿它保持……不，起初我是喜欢的。犹豫之所以出现，只是因为一旦这种事情失控，你就会知道对等且相反的反应将会到来。唯一的疑问是会发生在什么时候。唯一的疑问是会发生在什么时候。然后，在2000年5月，洛林的兄弟在去矿山的路上，顺便接了电话，因为电话当然在响，然后和英国的一个家伙聊了聊，
he said he was sitting there with his fiancée, he, having tea and crumpets. And he talked to him for a little while, and then continued on to Lareen's. And then in the morning morning when they were leaving, the booth was gone. In this case, the Equal and Opset reaction had come in the form of the National Park Service. It turned out the booth was almost smack dab in the center of a new national preserve.
那家伙说他和未婚妻正坐在那儿，喝着茶吃着烤饼。他跟他聊了一会儿，然后继续去洛林那儿。接着在早上，当他们离开时，电话亭不见了。在这种情况下，对等且相反的反应以国家公园管理局（National Park Service）的形式出现了。原来这个电话亭几乎正处于一个新建国家保护区的正中央。
When the phone had laid dormant, it hadn't been a problem. But park officials hadn't taken kindly to all the new foot traffic, War for that matter, the ringing. By the time Doc figured out what was happening, it was already too late. Did you go out and see this for yourself? No, no. I didn't go out until I think about, oh, 2009, 2010, long, long after. I mean, once I knew it was gone, there was, I didn't want to go out. Oh, 2009, 2010, long, long after.
当这个电话处于荒废状态时，它并不是个问题。但公园官员对所有新涌现的游客，或者更确切地说，对那铃声并没有什么好感。等“博士”弄清楚发生了什么时，已经太晚了。你有没有亲自去看看？没有，没有。直到我想大约在2009年、2010年，很久很久以后我才去。我的意思是，一旦我知道它没了，那就没有什么……我不想去。哦，2009年、2010年，很久很久以后。
I mean, once I knew it was gone, there was... I didn't want to go out. Why not? Just be too sad, you know? I mean... I had a lot of fun there. You know, what's funny too is that, uh... people did keep going out. And they would go and visit the concrete pad that the booth had stood on and a guy made a really nice tombstone for the booth and
我的意思是，一旦我知道它没了，那就……我不想去。为什么不呢？只会太伤感，你知道的？我的意思是……我在那儿度过了很多快乐的时光。你知道的，有趣的是，呃……人们还是不断地前往那里。他们会去参观那个曾经竖立着电话亭的混凝土底座，有个家伙甚至为电话亭做了一块非常漂亮的墓碑，还有
everything that anybody brought out there the park service hold off and eventually they came out and broke up the concrete pad and took that away to so it was like it was never there yeah when I was there the only thing left was a few pieces of glass from the broken windows. And people would say, yeah, well, it's not your phone loop. And I would say, yeah, I know, it's not my phone loop. But it's my fault.
人们带到那儿的所有东西都被公园管理局清理走了，最后他们甚至出来把混凝土底座也砸碎并运走了，所以它看起来就像从未存在过一样。是的，我去的时候，唯一剩下的就是碎窗户上的几块玻璃。人们会说，“好吧，这不是你的电话亭。”我会说，“是的，我知道，这不是我的电话亭。但这是我的错。”
You know, it wasn't as though I set out to make a phone loop famous far from it. It's just had I known I might not have done it. I mean, I might still, I don't know, but I might not have. Would the booth even hold the same appeal today, given that we can now reach anyone, anywhere? No, I mean, that's something that I have thought about is whether it could have happened even five years later.
你知道的，并不是说我刻意想让一个电话亭出名，远非如此。只是早知如此，我可能就不会这么做了。我是说，我可能还是会，我不知道，但我可能不会。鉴于我们现在可以随时随地联系到任何人，这个电话亭今天是否还具有同样的吸引力？不，我的意思是，我一直在想的一个问题是，如果事情发生在五年后，它是否还能发生。
And I just don't think it would have. I mean, that was kind of the magic of being in contact in an uncontactable place. And I don't think you have that feeling now. Did you ever try calling the number again after that? Oh, of course. Come on, Joe. Of course I did.
我觉得它不会发生。我的意思是，这就是在无法联系到的地方取得联系的魔力所在。我不认为你现在还会有那种感觉。在那之后你有没有尝试再拨打那个号码？哦，当然了。拜托，乔。我当然打过。
I mean, they let it ring for a long time. I mean, they left just even though the phone was not there. But... Would that even make sense? Because you're not even making a phone ring anymore in the desert. You're just making a kind of a... Oh, sure. I would know that, but still.
我的意思是，他们让它响了很长时间。我的意思是，他们甚至在电话已经不在的情况下任由它响。但是……这还有什么意义吗？因为你已经不再是在沙漠里让一个电话响了。你只是在制造一种……哦，当然。我心里明白，但还是。
It would be like listening to a song that meant something to you. I don't know. I don't know. I guess I did just like calling it out to the booth and hearing it ring in the end. The Mojave Phone Booth was produced by Joe Rosenberg for Oakland's own SNAP Judgment in 2014. Doc has a book coming out about all this called Adventures with the Mojave Phone Booth. We'll have a link on our website. Today if you call the Mojave Phone Booth number that's 760-733-9969, you'll connect to a conference line where you can talk to people from around the world.
这就好像听一首对你意义重大的歌。我不知道。我不知道。我想我只是喜欢把它呼叫到那个电话亭，最后听着它在荒野中响起。《莫哈韦电话亭》由乔·罗森伯格为奥克兰本土的《瞬息决断》制作于2014年。关于这一切，“博士”将出一本书，书名叫《莫哈韦电话亭历险记》。我们将在网站上提供链接。今天，如果你拨打莫哈韦电话亭的号码：760-733-9969，你将连接到一个会议热线，在那里你可以与来自世界各地的人交谈。
If no one's on the conference line, it plays a recording of the book exploding the phone, which is a really great book. But for the next week, you might just find someone from 99PI on the conference line. That's 760-733-9969 99% of visible is Sam Greenspan to Laney Hall, Kurt Colstad, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, Shereef Usef, and me Roman Mars. We are a production of 99% of visible ink, a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arxine, the finest architecture and interiors firm,
如果会议热线上没有人，它会播放一盘名为“电话大爆炸”的书籍录音，那真是一本很棒的书。但在接下来的一周里，你很可能会在会议热线上遇到来自“99PI”的人。号码是：760-733-9969。“99%隐形”制作团队包括萨姆·格林斯潘、兰妮·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯塔德、凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特吕夫曼、谢里夫·尤塞夫，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是“99%隐形”公司制作的节目，这是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的项目，制作工作室位于加利福尼亚州美丽的美丽市中心奥克兰的优秀建筑与室内设计事务所
in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. architecture and interiors for, in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and join the fine community of people who like this show on Facebook. I'll fave every 99 PI coin I see on Twitter and Instagram. But if you want to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world, I recommend you spend some time perusing 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Arxine的办公室。加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽市中心的建筑与室内设计事务所。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目，并加入喜欢这个节目的优秀社群。我会在Twitter和Instagram上为我看到的每一个“99 PI”硬币点赞。但如果你想探索塑造我们世界设计的“99%隐形”活动，我建议你花点时间浏览一下99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。